oh okay
okay so again to briefly briefly outline
the god and the other voices that are
internal but yes perceived as such
number two is language and music and
then chomsky and then objective truth
well i think the first two i have
covered either in what i've said or in
the book actually to some extent
but the last two are both very big
questions
and to me more interesting ones
i very much think like lake off and
johnson
about language and i find
chomsky's views i may simply not have
given them the credit that's due to them
of course
um but i i find them less attractive
because they seem more
um schematic more programmatic more like
the
there is a sort of software in the
hardware that
does certain things whereas i'm
a great believer in what one might call
the power of imitation in humans and i
spend quite a lot of time on
the fact that humans are particularly
good
at imitating um
not not just um copying but actually
imitating
and getting into the skin of another
creature
or another person and feeling something
about
how they are and why they are doing and
saying what they're doing
so i think language grows in this way as
i i've said from
a sort of a basic sense that is embodied
profoundly embodied in in movement in
the voice
in in music in the voice and
the the business of breath and that it
is
not really an abstract code
it can become that but it actually
i don't know that chomsky gives enough
credit to the way in which language is
constantly
metaphorising embodied experience and
takeoff and johnson very much do
show how every everything we say
has a reference that is understandable
in terms of the body and we can't get
deeper than that in a way
than our embodied experience um
it's where as wittgenstein said i hit
bedrock and my spade is turned you know
one can't dig down any further but it's
from there that that language comes